but you know dealing with the struggles
that we're all dealing with in these
difficult times sometimes you might feel
like maybe you're tilting at windmills
and perhaps maybe sometimes there's a
little Don Quixote in all of us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so we all have the impossible dream the
quest of Don Quixote we can do this
whatever it is that you're going through
these are difficult times for all of us
and we're all doing the best we can
sherry come on in yes we sure can we are
trying and and now we're getting back
there Nate we sure are trying to get
back to normal so we really appreciate
all the music that you bought brought
tests on Flutey 2d Friday it is uh it's
a joy for me and the response from the
viewers and folks out in public want to
keep it going and we want to keep
ourselves going as we get through all of
this together yeah very good Nate thank
you so much thank you and a walk free
opening today folks all across in the
valley so be safe out there and have a
good weekend